there was no specific mention of the
long fought over marbles in the --use
Draft negotiating mandate for a trade
deal but that didn't stop the
speculation that Greece was pushing to
get the artifacts back the demand that
unlawfully removed cultural artifacts
should be returned seen by many in the
UK as a threat work was continuing at
the European Council in Brussels today
to get a firm text agreed before trade
talks start next month
afternoon mr. Barney how are you and the
man who will be leading those
negotiations called for calm on both
sides of the channel once again I'm
going to work with the ambassadors as I
did yesterday with a parent to to get my
mandate at the beginning as soon as
possible in negotiations we have no time
I have no time for any politics on both
side and both side we have to keep calm
and to face the reality to face the
truth and to assume the consequences
it's not just a battle between the eu-27
and the UK different countries have
different priorities the French are said
to be playing hardball on getting rights
and access to UK waters into the mandate
but the mood in Brussels certainly
hasn't been helped by a bullish
intervention from the UK's brexit
negotiated David Frost this week
demanding a Canada style trade deal
which would free the UK from following
many EU regulations if you look back
right at the very beginning what the EU
was offering the UK was a Canada style
deal in fact one of the slides that
Michel Barney had presented to European
Council members some two or three years
ago included precisely a Canada style
deal so that is what the government our
government is looking to get and I think
we will get there there's no such offer
on the table Michel Barnier retorted in
his own speech reminding people Boris
Johnson had agreed just months ago to
abide by the EU s rules in areas such as
social and environmental protections
what the EU calls the level playing
field to stop the block being undercut
in trade
by a close neighbor you would expect at
the moment very tough negotiating
positions neither side will reveal how
far they're willing to go the key
question is what does that landing zone
look like and do we have time to reach
it the time factor is a real issue Boris
Johnson insisting a trade deal must be
struck by the year's end and the fear is
if no-one budges there will be no deal
at all Michele Clifford Sky News
Brussels